hey guys welcome back to new rockstars
I'm Sam bash today I'm here to talk
about Marvel and Netflix is series The
Punisher the MCU Punisher debuted last
year during the sophomore season of
daredevil and with such a positive
response to Jon Bernthal performance as
Frank Castle both Studios greenlit a
solo series for the antihero of my
cookie thoughts while the series was a
slow build I thought this was the most
consistent of the Netflix Marvel series
I really enjoyed it
this is one of the most human takes on
Frank Castle and Jon Bernthal killed it
Punisher intended also i think mike rowe
is one of the best supporting characters
that these shows have ever introduced
and I love the show's intro the intro
graphic is so cool but enough with what
I think you're gonna hear my excited
thoughts on this on my podcast on my
stupid answers a little plug right now
I'm gonna point out every reference an
easter-egg you kids missed from the
series spoiler warning of course for the
series all connected Marvel Netflix
shows the comics etc let's get going
let's kick it off with comic book
references everybody's favorites
starting with one of the first scenes in
episode 1 we're introduced right away to
the Punisher mobile or the correct name
the battle van which you guys remember
it was used to smoosh bikers
then it's very popular in the comics and
is usually pretty plain it's not really
flashy at all just a generic looking van
you guessed it filled with guns of
course we even get it to battle bands in
this season the one in Episode one and
then the second one the micro and Frank
steel speaking of episode one we meet
Frank's other secret identity cast a
Leone this is actually pretty fun to
throw back to Frank's ancestors who
immigrated from Sicily in their original
last name was cast Leone not castle of
course that's how it works like in in
humans when black bolts real name is
black a guard bolt agon say that name
easily so you got Punisher a circle of
blood for more info on that
another big punisher story gets a great
shout out that most fans picked up on
immediately one of my crows first lines
to Frank is compact which is the title
of one of the most popular Punisher
series there is shout out to Garth Ennis
so many goodies in episode 1 let's keep
it going with the dum-dums who decided
to rob a crime families card game Nucci
or canoe see if you'd like that's
correct it's the same family name in
welcome back Frank the series who are
the main antagonists specifically Magen
uchi who could possibly show up in
future seasons as an antagonist who
knows maybe speaking of an antagonist
there's a possibility for multiple
characters on the show taking a turn to
the dark side like Curtis Hoyle the
leader of the veterans support group and
one of my favorite characters from this
season is actually more of a villain in
the comics actually he's got a pretty
hardcore name the dragon but he's barely
in the comics he dies pretty quick
because it's the Punisher you know how
these things work
speaking of villains one of our main
antagonist from the show Agent Orange
aka William Rollins is actually a sort
of mash up of two different characters
only in name though meaning that there
is an agent orange in the comics who
looks like this but his name is Roger
Gosha and he's an agent of shield that
turns bad and then there's William
Rollins who is a Punisher villain from
garthe nemesis Punisher max series which
is amazing by the way and he's one of
the few Punisher villains that as far as
I can tell is still running around still
kickin his story is very much the same
in the comics as well of trafficking
drugs from Afghanistan and he's got the
whole one I think owing on in the comics
though he's got a pretty sick patch but
still the same one another funny comic
book nod remember when Lewis one of our
other antagonists of the series is
watching TV with his father they're
watching the rumble in the jungle match
between Muhammad Ali
George Foreman back in 1974 that year is
important because that's actually the
debut year of the Punisher in Marvel
Comics in the Amazing Spiderman at
number 129 right also this one might be
a stretch but someone pointed out online
that Lewis's father clay Wilson could be
a nod to clay Wilson in the comics who
plays the villain force maybe his comic
book character could be introduced on
the show as a way to bring Lewis's
storyline back for season two that's a
stretch
honestly no idea but what I do know is
that Senator Stan Horry is important do
you remember him right he's the guy
who's anti-gun he ran on Charon in the
middle of a shootout kind of a man
character if I'm being honest he is
actually affiliated with the Mafia in
the comics and Frank spoiler alert and
kills his son so maybe we'll see him
again in the future who knows two more
comic book nods and I'm saving a good
one for you guys remember when Frank is
being patched up by Madonna's father I
agree this would be a perfect time to
bring in Rosario Dawson's Claire temple
onto the show but hey I'll take what I
can get you remember this line here the
purple might be your color this actually
feels like a fun nod to the first
punisher one piece that he wore in the
spider-man comic originally though suit
that he wore was purple and light I mean
Jon Bernthal does look good in purple
but I don't want to wear that and last
comic book reference Jiggs aka Billy
Russo you guys knew this was coming and
I wanted to savor the reveal jigsaw is
one of the biggest villains in the
Punishers rogues gallery in the comics
Frank is the one responsible for turning
Billy the beaut Russo into jigsaw and we
actually get some fun teases to Billy's
fate earlier in the season when Curtis
and Billy meet up for one of the first
times in the series we hear mention that
he's good at putting people back
together
he was we're good at putting people back
together jigsaw puzzles pulling things
together putting them together you get
it all so I kind of really hope we get a
second season so that we could see what
kind of makeup they're gonna do for
Billy is known we scary that's enough of
that though let's talk about MCU
connections the ones you guys need and
you want there's a good handful of nods
to other Marvel Netflix shows Marvel
movies and other Marvel shows on
different networks link first off again
with episode 1 the dogs of Hell the
biker gang they got mowed down by Frank
also showed up in daredevil season 2 and
we're also mowed down by Frank and then
knocked out by Daredevils pretty
cool but fun fact they were also seen in
the Marvel TV series agents of shield
they were in that fun episode in season
one with the Asgardian villain Lorelei
lady SIF showed up yay crossovers
actually speaking of shield we've
actually heard one of the Punisher
supporting cast members named before on
shield during the shield episode the
writing on the wall we heard Skye
mention her contact micro specifically
saying one of my sources this guy micro
he's kind of a crime scene junkie he
came across something what is this
something well you're gonna have to
watch agents of shield I highly
recommend it shield has mentioned some
types of daredevil as well before but
does this mean we're gonna get a
crossover in the future probably not
we've been burned before but hey don't
give up hope kids yeah we do get a you
know mini crossover with a couple
characters that have popped up on
multiple MCU Netflix shows one being
Karen obviously from daredevil and she
showed up into the defenders we see
Brett Mahoney the police officer from
daredevil defenders and more and we get
Turk Barrett the infamous the criminal
who can't seem to catch a break from all
these street-level vigilantes whether it
be Harlem or Hell's Kitchen he's and
never safe but fun fact it seems in this
show Punisher has claimed Queens as his
domain you all know who's usually
stomping around Queens certain webhead
and I don't think he'd be super thrilled
bumping into Frank while he's working
speaking of MCU this one is very
missable so pay attention if you go
ahead and zoom in on this scene right
here where Lois accidentally kills the
imposter veteran you'll notice the film
Black Widow now of course this isn't
scar Joe's like Widow from the embassy
but it definitely feels like a clever
nod so thank you
keep it on with the references remember
when Frank accidentally reveals that
he's still alive on national television
that's a whoops but what is that station
again mmm wh i H oh yes that's the
station we were introduced to after age
of Ultron very cool we even got this
interview with Scott Lang while he's
still in prison check it out we also get
another nod to a media outlet in the MCU
our friend Karen and Senator ory hop
onto a radio show to discuss the
Punisher and the gun control debate and
this station goes by the name W and E X
which should sound familiar to Jessica
Jones fans sense the same station host
wrist talk with Trish Walker
I wish she popped up on this series I'm
being honest Trish did make an
appearance on the defenders which was
pretty neat as well that show got a few
nods in this season by the way the
defenders one major reference and one
more subtle that some people have
pointed out
you look at the newspaper that Mitchell
Ellison is holding you can read chaos
under the streets would seems to be
talking about during the finale of the
defenders when they decided to blow up a
building to bury that skeleton of that
dragon underneath New York and maybe
accidentally kill Elektra in the hand
and daredevil but people online have
also mentioned that the red lights that
we can see on the Empire State Building
could be a nod to the death of daredevil
since the show probably happens just
after the events of the defenders I mean
could it be for daredevil do enough
people know about him is he that big I
mean know what you think down below
keeping it moving let's talk about that
kick-ass takedown where Frank knocks
that dude onto that pinball machine
looks an awful lot like that diamond
statue toy model no I think yes very
cool what's cooler to me are the nods to
the Thomas Jane Punisher movie I know
it's not perfect but it's got a special
place in my heart
specifically spray-painting on the body
armor just like Thomas Jane did and
lastly all let's talk about the
references to other forms of media
whether it be novels or TV shows or
movies that clearly inspired moments or
entire episodes for the Punisher series
throughout this season we get a few
characters reading famous novels which
line up pretty well with their character
story
you see Frank reading Moby Dick a story
about a man who became obsessed with
killing his white whale you know he's
blinded by his obsession which is pretty
much the Punishers MO that's what all he
does he kills people who killed his
family no matter the cost
yeah we also see Billy reading Dorian
Gray which is fun for two reasons one
because Dorian Gray sells us off to stay
youthful and beautiful which lines up
pretty well with Billy's whole handsome
thing that he's got going on Billy the
Butte to Ben Barnes actually played
Dorian Gray in the movie adaptation from
a few years ago crossover again we also
get a lot of nods and parallels to
classic cinema and stories like Dirty
Harry a cop who goes rogue and kills a
serial killer is very similar to Frank's
plot for this season and always in
everything we also get a nod to Full
Metal Jacket which is smart since the
original Punisher served during the
Vietnam War and not in Afghanistan but
we even get a specific line recreated
does this mean that Aunt Margaret's not
coming does this mean that ann-margret
is not coming now if you're Steve
McQueen fan you were definitely really
feeling that Frank vs Madani car chase
when Madonna is literally driving the
same 68 Mustang that Steve McQueen drove
in Bullitt and finally some people
online have pointed out some interesting
similarities between Lewis's character
and Travis Bickle in taxi driver they
both drive taxis they both vets
suffering from PTSD who end up snapping
and they
violent I'm sorry I lied last two fun
nods because you guys deserve a little
treat a whiteboard behind Ellison at the
newspaper has some of the crews names
written on it from the Punisher series
McDonald as you can see is one of the
set dressers and s or Scott Murphy is a
production designer for this show
daredevil and Luke Cage season two and
lastly of course Stanley does pop up in
this series but it's literally the
shortest cameo ever blink and you'll
miss it I did a bunch of times he's
right there on that poster in the park
oh we did it anyways that's it from me
guys thank you so much for tuning in if
I pointed out some fun facts that you
hadn't caught before or if you think I
missed something let me know in the
comments down below be sure to like this
video subscribe to new rockstars and
check out more of our breakdowns
I'm Sam basher I talk about the flash
all the time on Twitter and on this
channel and I'll see you guys next time